for now
i'm starting this tournament
it's uh
the u chicago
plus rosen arena ooh
so i guess i'm berserking
and
let's not start with a stafford because
i'm playing a decently high rate of
player
um we'll play a time whatever whatever
this is
this is some like kind of closed
sicilian type thing
knight c6 is a playable move
so this is kind of like bullet chest now
but uh i get away with taking this
let's try
oh
did i already blunder
i kind of did
it's a strong move
be tricky i have this move
maybe it's okay
oh no it's not okay
okay um
i could resign i got tricked in the
opening
let's play this move let's fight on
it's already like not
looking so good for me
oh no my queen
but after knight f6 takes takes takes i
get a lot of material for the queen
i'm gonna keep the bishop hair
i'm very much alive it's actually
considered equal material
but slightly unequal time
it is nice having the bishop here too
okay
thankful white didn't take the pawn
there
try and make some progress
that's still difficult though
um
especially timewise
okay we'll push an a pawn
now this is risky but
i'm trying to hold on
ooh okay we'll take
as we're trading more
yeah my pawn
oh that was a useful pre-move
oh well played though
okay ah that was a cool a good game
though
nice game to start off the tournament
um
okay so i lost did i lose points sir
i guess i lost some reading points
but it'll be a long tournament
um
again this is a close tournament unless
you're a uchicago student or alum
uh they did invite me to play this so
i'll try and uh i'll try and keep this
instructive keep this entertaining for
the chat
oh zado wonder oh was that a wonder
it's a wonder
oh this is a wonder i play the wonder
i didn't wait is a wonder part of you
chicago
oh wonder like i um i grew up playing
him
i played him for the first time when he
was like seven
i had no idea that was a wonder because
he's a gm
but i guess he needs to still like
verify his title on
uh only chess
i know liang
liang liang
it's a common last name
among a lot of a lot of chess players
so
okay i don't feel so bad
yeah he did outplay me that game
um he tricked me in the opening still
got a playable position
a wonder is probably one of my most
played opponents over the board
because we played so many times over the
years
yeah there's only 16 people playing this
tournament so
might take more time than usual to
to get a game okay playing cyber vision
um not beers working i'm gonna play
hopefully normal solid chess
okay so london with a6
not sure if it makes a huge
difference i'll still go for the usual
plan of c4 queen b3
ooh
interesting move
i'm out of prep but i still know ideas
to pressure the queen side
oh u.s junior field is not officially
announced okay
a vampire chicken would know
i know us chess champs is uh the place
to find all the information
us chesschamps.com
okay let's um
get away with taking and taking
maybe
some pressure along the c file
also thank you stephen gray
oh and thanks to vampire chicken
i'm pretty sure they scheduled the dates
for us us junior
and u.s senior maybe
happening at the same time
okay so if takes takes
i think that actually just wins material
knight a5
would be an attempt but then queen a4
and it takes i probably take with
seeking knight
access to dark squares
i should calculate knight c4 takes
knight b3 knight b6
looks to be okay you're welcome if a
vampire chicken bites you do you become
a vampire or a chicken
um
there's only one way to find out right
but i'm not gonna be volunteering to be
bin
also i'm up upon here
but after it takes takes this d-pawn
might be
a slight target
oh i'm throwing a fork too
which i couldn't really play previously
because the bishop would be hanging
oh vampire chicken says you don't want
to find out okay
that was a good question though
do chickens bite people
or it's just
just
vampire chickens or vampires
like chickens
don't have teeth
or do they
it's been a while since i've seen a
chicken
let's play knight c4 or e4
so indecisive
i'll play bishop c4 already up a pawn
might as well complete development and
still apply pressure
oh it's teotwaki
oh no my tts i have to figure out what's
going on
it still might be a bug with uh the
whole system
but thanks for the donation testing the
tts
castle here
yeah
there there's probably other options but
uh just looking to play solidly and
try and keep the extra pawn advantage
if b5 there's on passant
i could take with rook two i'll dig with
queen
some 95 ideas
um
i think i still want to play knight e5
i could also take and play 95
now the threat is to take the bishop and
take the knight
yeah not an easy position for black if
bishop f5 i might have g4
so 96 is probably best
and we could trade
i'll just play b4
just reinforce everything
thank you lanuman subbing for 14 months
maybe queen here
ensuring i'm controlling the d file
there might be some idea knight c4
and then get the knight to a better
place or even this knight
this knight's already on a good square
now if b5
on passant would be legal but not good
thankfully i won't have to have that
sort of moral dilemma
okay so this knight's coming in
threatening the fork
i will bring this knight to the center
man a wonder has 11 points
i have yet to win a game
uh
i feel like i'm close to winning though
i can take this
ooh
so e4
this is a fork i was threatening earlier
this looks weird but
it could also take
let's keep the knights on the board
oh if knight f4
black is threatening a fork
but then okay queen e3
eventually be winning more material
or winning on time
okay or winning by resignation
okay thanks for the game cyber vision
okay get a game immediately playing
p-k-k-a-s
i guess i'll deserve
um because i'll try and
i'll try and fight my way back in the
tournament
give my opponent some time odds have a
london
i'll probably mix up the openings too
should mix in some e4
yeah so with queen b6 i like to play
knight c3
offering the pawn
after which knight b5 is very strong
i think a3 is a move here
still offering the pawn but then i would
trap the queen
i think i can still
still play knight a4
so defending attacking if check i play
c3 defending
if that i can take the pawn
so yeah some tricky london line
is paying off
won the very crucial c5 pawn
so now there's less ways for black to
pressure the center
get the knight in
and this queen b6 line can be dangerous
if white's not prepared
there are probably some better ways to
pressure the
position i'm just gonna go
go bananas here
go for the quick king side attack
g4 i wouldn't play this if black wasn't
already committed to h6
but because of h6g the prospect of g5 is
really strong
just open the g file
it's a very reasonable move play rook g1
losing casting rights on the king side
and still wanting to play this
yeah i have to be very careful because i
lost uh increments
play each four
get all the pawns rolling
okay pawns are ready to storm
no need to storm immediately
it's better to be calm before the storm
just slowly building up so now the
knights attack twice
if it goes back uh then g5 happens
and probably what i want to do like if
knight d6 i don't play g5 because then
h5
although that looks good too
okay let's take the bishop and
win a pawn
okay so now the the main concern is just
time
go for this
there's a line f5 queen e2 h5 95 is
is nice
95 still on the horizon
maybe i'll take with rook
no 95 first
the problem is i might have to trade
queens and then
grind down the end game
with little time
if we can keep queens on the board that
would be
preferable
okay now the plans to castle put the
rook here
knight does a good job defending though
so i might want a triple battery
get the gun on the g file
and maybe even just shift over to h file
g7 is well defended but
h8 is not well defended
i'm not interested in taking on f7
if king tries to run i make it go back
and then mate
yeah pieces are optimized
queen side attack is a little bit too
slow
if knight h6i take it i think it's force
mate
okay it's a nice kind of london attack
interesting opening too
[Music]
um okay
so trying to catch up to a wonder who's
berserk winning all the
games i honestly had no idea i wonder
he's probably a student at uchicago oh
i'm playing uh w grave
the um
i think he's this is a president of the
chicago chess team
um
let's play sicilian
play e6
and d5
have a little bit of prep here
she'll see if i can remember
i remember so
my opponent uh played a match against
one of my friends many months ago
and i prepared exactly this opening for
my friend
which now i'm playing myself
idea is to
white's actually playing a line that i
like to play as white this queen two
grand prix
um so i close down the center i kick the
knight
now i'll play this move
this is still preparation so i want to
play b5 next
yeah this is all preparation now d3
it's the last move of of my prep
um but it's a very timely move because i
disturbed the position
for white and
oh i remember further actually
i think it's 95
weirdly enough
i think this is a extent of the prep
threatening knight b3
i might have to review this at some
point
so i sack a pawn i put the nylon edge
but there's there's some issue
on the queen side for white
i have to look this over
at some point later
it is nice being prepared early getting
the early time advantage
especially being prepared in a
slightly lesser common line
okay so now i'll play this
kind of forking rook be one's force now
this move and the pawn is hard to defend
if i can win this pawn
eventually i'll want to move back and
pressure d3
oh but that's a tricky move
if i take then there's knight b6
and giving me a taste of my own medicine
so i probably want to play rook here
first
pawn is still hanging this pawn's under
pressure
if knight b6 i probably play bishop c6
yeah it's a positional gambit
so i'm not winning back upon immediately
but i'm getting some
interesting pressure
and this bishop is going to be stuck for
a long long time
but with all that said like lights up a
pawn if i don't get something concrete
soon
it could be worse
a5 i'll play bishop b5
it's so weird having my knight here like
it's so deep in white's crib
and it's not defended but it's hard to
attack
maybe just bishop e7
i'm realizing it's hard for white to do
much
bishop can't move the rook can't move
this knight is kind of pinned to the
pawn
pawn can't really advance because it's
tied down to defending the knight
king's tie down to the pawn
so it's really only these things which
can kind of move
but this rook can't do much
white's almost completely paralyzed here
amazingly enough
of course there's waiting moves
my plan is probably to castle double up
except
maybe play f6 first
oh then that wants to come this way
interesting
play king f7
oh i do still want to double up
i think this pawn's going to be lost
eventually
oh is there a prediction there is a
prediction in twitch on whether or not i
would castle
i was thinking about castling but f6
king f7
turned out to be
a bit preferable
so f5 oh f5 is actually a pretty good
move
because if i play this the knight has
amazing square on d5 so i think i have
to take
d-pawn should still be
weak
yeah and if the pawn or knight takes
then there's no possibility of knight d5
happening soon
man oh wonder has 21 points
i guess i'm not berserking this game so
it's taking
uh more time
oh rook have fun
so takes takes
maybe i'll just leave the pawn and play
this move
because i don't want i don't want to
give white the option of unleashing the
bishop
take this way
okay so now i think i should cash in
i could take this thing
that wins two miners for the
the rook
okay so white's finally allowing the
bishop to escape
but i'll have two bishops for the rook
and
should be a pretty routine win
um
oh no my pawn
okay
uh let's play this move
no
let's be reasonable let's play this move
maybe preparing c4
i'll bring my king in
maybe this move eventually
yeah bishops are very nice to have an
endgame
just expand on all sides
yeah playing very patiently
i guess i should probably look to win
more quickly
making good progress
and now the f pawn will run
down the board
bishop can block the checks
or support the pawn
okay that was a nice game
interesting opening prep
um
took a bit of time to convert
might be hard to catch the um
catch a wonder here
looks like he has a slightly difficult
position
i think you've worse still in matt
subbing for five months
oh i'm playing the same person okay i'll
go for a stafford
because i've last game with sicilian
haven't tried this yet
oh no stafford maybe we'll have a
bowdoin kizuritski ooh
so i'll transpose him to center fork
trick
taking is also adequate but um then
white would be
having a fun gambit
so
[Music]
there's a b3 i don't think i've ever
seen that move before
i guess i
wow
that's a cool move
i don't have too much time to deliberate
i guess i just taken it's a reverse
stafford with the bishop here instead of
here
so it should be very similar
i think this is a key move just stopping
all the tricks with knight g5
and i'll play
i'll play as if it was a reverse
stafford
and maybe give white a pawn cube
thanks to people from earlier too who
maybe i missed
bagel yet slaving with prime dreams of
melody subbing for one year
oh from bordeaux france
i was learning french earlier
or trying to learn french how to say
bishop
i should probably move a little bit
quicker
position's nice though i have 75 of a
pawn cube
won the castle and attack on the king
side
yeah usually in stafford
sometimes it's better for white to
castle queen side
makes things a bit more sharp
do i look more tan
i see the comment from the beast
i got a decent amount of sun yesterday
played some tennis
maybe got a small tan
i don't get tan by streaming
chess inside though
okay making progress
so yeah in this sort of situation the
pawns should be on light squares
to more complement the bishop
and the knight can fit in
actually all the pieces have
attacking potential
on the king side
i just really have to watch time
my f3 is a fun threat
because if knight f3 takes takes it's a
fork
threatening the queen and mate
and the three in itself is a fork
threatening the knight in king
yeah i think i can still get away with
this
now if takes takes a pawn can take but
then after rook takes
i think rook h3 is hard to stop
another funny line is if takes takes
rook g1 i take
uh we trade queens but then my queen is
reborn
as i win a rook
and this is uh
probably force mates
only a few ways for white to delay the
inevitable
okay i'm in clear second but uh still a
big gap between second and first
thanks for the game again p k k a s
picas
it's like an abbreviated pikachu
okay 14 points i think my goal is to
stay at half the number of points as a
wonder
very important question from marty mcfly
there's a video
[Music]
oh there is this video on youtube where
you play eric hanson
over the board outside of a cafe
oh it wasn't outside of a cafe it was
outside the st louis chess club
but maybe it looked like a cafe
and the question is
is berserk again was a game-winning
dirty move accidental or on purpose
um
i think the game the video you're
referring to eric made an illegal move
to finish the game
but i don't think i've intended to be
dirty
he just didn't realize where i put my
rook he was expecting a different move
um i know which video you're referring
to i'll have to go back and watch that
i think it's called eric versus eric
from a few years ago
okay playing being the shadow haven't
played before
i'm playing an orthostop by the way
this is an ortho schnapp declines
i'm getting a pleasant structure
develop
i might want to go for some eventual
push
put the rook here
yeah so even though my knight's not
defended there's some potential attack
the prospect of f4 f5 is nice and
light can be still defended
maybe by the queen or by the pawn
yeah let's bring the queen in
this is a very fun position to attack
usually when you're white and you have a
pawn e5
it's a sign you should attack on the
king's side
i'm probably already threatening to take
on h6
because takes takes
threatening mate if f5 i win the bishop
if g6 here i sack more stuff
gg6 knight takes g6
threatening bishop g7
too much fun
hey it's clearcast chess
thanks for the raid
raiding at a fun moment
am i meeting
it's very close to mate
where's my mate
play bishop f6
yeah shout out to clear cast chess
fellow chess streamer
i assume
for those just joining i'm playing a u
chicago arena tournament
um it's a closed event so
if you're not a uchicago student
you'll just have to watch
but having some fun games
instructive games some berserking games
very close to mating here
uh there we go
okay thanks for the game yeah that's uh
that's a tricky opening though with her
schnapp
i feel like these days if you play the
french
it's an important one to know how to
deal with
yeah if you're a you chicago alum you
should probably
um
i think there's
there's some way of getting in
maybe for future events
i'm not sure if you can join if you're a
chicago dropout
but yeah people i think if you go to the
tournament link you can at least watch
the games
um
i'm not gonna berserk i'm gonna play
play my usual stuff
play a london
try and keep a streak
play the
so i'm less prepared um
at least against a specific opponent
but uh still prepared in the london
so i'll play bishop b5 yeah bishop b5
it's um
a move it's a newer ish move
there's a time where i used to always
just play c3 and kind of be more passive
but the point of bishop b5 is to play a
quick c4
also sometimes a quick 95.
and yeah black's actually walking into
one of the main traps here
if pawn takes i'm going to trap the rook
rookie bishop e7
the bishops take away all the squares
from the rook
thank you going to go mad
subbing for 16 months
any resources i'd recommend for learning
queen's camp
declined um
i guess you could take a look at my
games like use opening tree
to see my qgd rapper tour
because i um
[Music]
oh i have to be careful because this is
a threat
maybe this move
just trying to trade down
i don't mind the double pawns especially
because i have the c file now
and this is met with this defending both
pawns
yeah sometimes the best way to learn an
opening is to
find like a strong player who plays that
opening consistently and then study
their games and get a sense of their
repertoire
uh this could be slightly annoying
maybe queen a4 here
just calculating this and then this and
or know this and then this and then this
i just want to castle and be safe
calculating um
castling queen b2 queen c6
lose a pawn in the end there
okay i could castle and play knight b3
dedicate this move to knight b3
yeah so i defend this pawn i try and
restrict the queen from retreating
and both these pawns are hanging
probably not trapping the queen
because it has few too many squares
i mean the goal is just to win the pawn
back
if rook c8 defending c6 i play rook c1
thank you con con
bildique
i feel like that might be pronounced
chonchon
or janja
not sure if that's turkish or indonesian
ooh
oh i really want to take here say oh no
my queen but it's not me because bishop
f8
so
i guess i have to trade queens i have
this move too
[Music]
but i can play that later i'll trade
95
c5 might happen
[Music]
if bishop b4 i take and threaten this
and this
yeah so the pawn is pinned
play rook b1
it's advantage when you're up the
exchange
sometimes the best way to make use of it
is to exploit the files
so this is a half open file this is a
fully open file
oh this move trap oh no it doesn't trap
the bishop because the rook's defended
but i can take the pawn now
[Music]
could be some back rank opportunities
so bishop takes i play rook c1
here we trade
there's a weird line
i want to play rook c7 here i don't know
if it works
i guess i can calculate rook c7 takes
takes
bishop has to move somewhere if here i
play here
moves elsewhere i still play here
i think it's okay
this is completely not necessary it's
just for the style points i guess
it's also to make my opponent think
um
i don't see anything wrong with this
like i temporarily lose a knight but i
win the pawn
and then
the key is rook b7 exploiting the back
rank
now if the pawn were on d5 i don't think
the calculation would work
because takes takes here here there
would be knight t5
preserving bishop f8
if i wanted to be simple i should have
just played
knight c6
a more practical move
and yeah once i win the pawn
oh i'm not winning the pawn
oh but maybe i'll win more than the pawn
so i have this move
double
it's a skewer and a
i mean there's bishop at f8 but
the bigger concern is the skewer
called check and fork
okay um
yeah interesting game
uh that game i guess it was a matter of
improving in the opening for black as
bishop e5 london can be
weirdly tricky
okay still in second
a wonder crashing through i have exactly
half the points
um
23 to 46
and berserk winning every game
oh we're playing okay i'll be rick back
let's try a stafford this time
oh let's take
he was probably expecting something else
okay so we have center fork trick
it takes d5 bishop d3 is what i'm
expecting bishop d5
that's interesting
so this is like a
reverse stafford
similar to the previous game
but the bishop is here
um
let's defend
kind of
i have to be really careful here
leaving my king in the center
i should castle soon
so if we trade
play this move
under a little bit of pressure
so it takes
[Music]
this move
i'm building up a center
c4d4 maybe now i have e4
i'm okay with the trade
two rooks for a queen
i always have to watch my time
oh
interesting okay i have this move
and these pawns are magnificent
uh
play g5
now they're more magnificent let's play
this and
okay with trading
almost a pawn cube for white
interesting let's play this
okay now it's just a matter of not
flagging or blundering
anything simple
uh
[Music]
expecting c6
i just want to get the king to d5 okay
hey i want a game
uh nice game yeah that was uh
it's weird like i've never encountered
bishop d5 but i
was somewhat prepared with ideas because
it was almost exactly a reverse stafford
okay
move on
i don't think there's a chance of
catching up to first but
it is nice to keep a streak
and yeah i think bishop c4 was played
anticipating knight
knight c6
so i'm pretty sure he would have taken
the on e5 if uh
if bishop c4 wasn't almost pre-moved
okay
ooh let's berserk i'll play e4
whoa it's gotham chess what's up gotham
chess
raiding after
what uh after a cool game
for everyone joining i just beat
of
a decently strong grandmaster
but thanks for the raid hope you had a
good stream
shout out to gotham
we have a gotham command
if you haven't heard of gotham
he's an up-and-coming
chess youtuber
people should sub to him on youtube
good job on giving him his first loss of
the tournament oh thank you stephen gray
gotham is also an up and coming rapper
he just released like um epic
diss track
he actually he inspired me like
when i um
when or if i hit a million subs on
youtube
i'm gonna release a uh
well first i have to learn how to rap
but if i manage to learn how to rap oh i
could have taken the pawn
um
let's take a pawn
oh no my bishop
someday i'll release a diss track
oh this is going very nice
c6 bishop c6 and then queen b7 mate
or no
depending where the king goes
king c8 and it's made in two
okay
that was nice
thank you b quinn and beneficius
i might see gotham soon gotham's going
to vegas
i'm still trying to figure out if i'm
going to vegas
but i feel kind of inspired to to play
some over-the-board chess
also for those just joining i should
explain what i'm doing
um i'm playing chess
it's uh
it's a closed tournament i'm basically a
guest in the u chicago
[Music]
arena so i'm trying to take down members
and
members and graduates of uchicago chess
team um
i could bizwork here let's not bizarre
let's play
something reasonable
like a budapest
haven't played one of these in recent
memory
so knight f3 it's most accurate to play
bishop c5
oh
alexa
drop some mad beats on us
okay here's beet cylinder
later home slice ooh
what
sue my dumplings wait what how's it
going everyone it's jeff tila here on
the set of family food showdown and i
want to show you a food that uh i grew
up quickly in my family alexa stop it
they wanted to show me how to cook
cantonese dumplings
which sounds delicious but i think
that's a bit different from
some mad beats
anyway okay i like the position i won
back the
the pawn
um
play a5 here
so there's an idea in the budapest which
doesn't happen in so many other openings
is to develop the rook like a noob
and play this in this
which can actually be kind of powerful
in certain cases
oh cantonese beats like not
musical rhythm
but like beats like
um bears beats and battle galactica i
think
different type of beat okay let's um
lift the rook
that's why i wanted to teach me how to
make food
okay i should really make an effort to
stay focused here
i just want to defend defend the knight
lift the rook play d6
bring the bishop in
and eventually mate
white's going to have some weird counter
play though like this move is probably
coming
this move would threaten the bishop and
my knight
so what to do
to play c6
knight e4 is actually a really strong
threat
it's good to realize that here and not
realize it
after it's too late
i guess i could play rookie 894 bishop
a7
let's do that
so i over defend the knight anticipating
this
and bishop a7 is nice my rook's already
made its way
it's it's already began the journey
so bishop a7 doesn't really interfere
with anything
and then there's some long-term idea of
putting the bishop on b8
to keep the other bishop company
because it's hibernation season and then
eventually play c6
or maybe like rook here c6
and then unleash the diagonal
and the bishops go from hibernating to
hunting
these are still all like kind of typical
budapest ideas
one of the reasons why i really like
this opening
so white might play this move
to attack my rook
but it only provokes me to kind of carry
through with my plans
we might also simplify at some point
but let's swing over
i want to make sure that's over here
that was remarkably soothing
thanks for the
the noise
small cat
okay d6 probably
i don't own a sprinkler it's one of the
things with like renting an apartment
i'm not responsible for
gardening
i could play rook f6
playbook f6 just see what white is up to
try and drain some more time
g6
now maybe bishop h3
yeah i'm realizing the bishop should
stay here align with the king
and this queen is almost trapped
oh there's a funny line rook f6
wait it doesn't work or does it
it almost
works it kind of might work but it might
not
so rook f6 queen h4 rook f2
what is this
wait
so if queen e7 rook g2 it's good for me
if king f2
knight g4 bishop g4 queen e3 mate
if queen a tree rookie 2 that's also
good for me so what am i scared of
queen e7 no
bishop e5
bishop b5 is kind of scary but then i
take on each four and take on e2
i think this is okay
what a move
oh but white plays that move but i still
have this move
got my time
but
cool move
okay i'm not i didn't calculate this
fully but similar to the other line
oh thanks for the money jamison king
oh you chicago alum here oh nice
oh did i just play you oh that's cool
okay so i'm gonna win the queen
and maybe mate
it's almost force mate
it's completely winning thankfully white
can't counter check mamie
queen g7 would be
slightly illegal
yeah kingy one i um i take here
that's a cool game
a nice demonstration of a budapest
attack
this is mate so bishop's pinned
okay that was fun
so the rook went on a journey look at
this rook journey
so rook from a to a6 to g6 to f6
i repeated a little bit
and then took on f2
should be a travel agent
just plan trips for for rooks
okay a wonder is still
i wonder is recovering from the
that one game
oh and he won connect connect4
i think you will will 139
and euler is subbing for 17 months
okay playing
oh let's uh let's berserk
because i am trying to maybe
miraculously catch up to first place
so i'll play a knight c3 sicilian
going for a grand prix
thank you meformer
subbing with prime
so black's playing the
the frowny face variation
but it's also the smiley face variation
um
what i wasn't i wasn't talking to you
siri
i don't know
oh it wants me to breathe
yeah every like few hours my apple watch
will remind me to breathe
i'm pretty sure i can do that without
needing to think about it
let's play
my d4 is kind of coming
this is actually kind of playable
for black
play this move
i still like the position
maybe could have could have gotten a bit
more but
one of the issues for black is uh the d5
square
i'll keep the bishop here there is this
move
oh my time is kind of low
let's try and win back a pawn
maneuver the knight attack upon
[Music]
not so simple
okay file is now half open for me
some idea knight c4
that's a good move i can take in knight
c4 attacking defending attacking
[Music]
black mites act exchange
just realize there's some pressure here
too
oh it's tricky
um should probably diff let's play queen
g4
getting off danger attacking e6
should probably throw an a32
[Music]
for example like rook
let's say rookie 8
oh this rook
to e8 i take the bishop
i'll play a3 so i want to chase the
queen away from defending the pawn
oh i had a tactic
i missed it though
oh but i still have it rook f6
i could have also taken here but this is
more um beautiful
check and then i'll oh maybe i'll get
some other mate
yeah should have just enough time to win
this
oh
okay it's force mate
oh no my queen
okay that was nice
that was close though i think black was
maybe
even better at some point with the queen
side pressure
but got the job done
okay
oh was there maybe there was a failed
prediction
some people are slightly disappointed
but some people are happy
the rooks survive apparently
first mother made of the stream
so 15 points away that's only three
berserk wins away
i think that's possible
oh
also a wonder is kind of in trouble i
think in this position
oh thank you puns of steel
with uh
what is this word new mono ultra
microscopic silico volcano gonios is the
world's longest word oh
i was gonna ask if that's valid in
scrabble but that probably wouldn't fit
on a
normal scrabble board
i would also ask my robot what it means
but
it seems too difficult to to repeat
but thanks for the bits puns of steel
and small cat
what's the longest the longest possible
scrabble word
would be 15
letters or tiles
scrabble board is 15 by 15. okay let's
um
let's play the pied person
i think i'm at my peak blitz rating
actually
i just realized that
i'm gonna go for never mind i wanted to
play budapest but
we're gonna try and take down the london
here
oh opponents playing what i recommend
um what do i play here
putin's well prepared
i'll play a solid line i actually had
this position earlier from the white
side
i played bishop b5
um this is more of a main line this is
actually a gambit line
oh no my pawn
there's some theory around this which
i don't think i'll fully remember
i don't think that's theory
unfortunately for whites it loses a
bishop
okay so opening prep paid off
oh
[Music]
oh what's the mate called there's a mate
where you sack your queen
and then mate with the bishops
let's try and get it
uh
[Music]
it might require some dubious place
really
i would probably believe that
oxy
oh i feel like that's the highest
scoring
possible scrabble word
oh that's meat okay i was dreaming of a
situation where
i take on c3 with a queen
and then deliver made on e3 with the
bishop
but that would have required the queen
to be elsewhere
okay
10 points out of first
oh
so will will won another upset
so i probably play a wonder next game
as white
or is black i don't know
or i might play will next game
i'm not sure
the chess is debating i'm playing a
wonder again okay i'll be zerk
so the last time i played the wonder
over the board he beat me
he took down my london
but he played a different line
he played more like king's indian menoni
um let's play this line
and then
wait a minute
i'm already confusing myself i want to
play this but it's not quite
working let's play this move
okay
get some reasonable position
um
[Music]
this work
wait takes on f7
i don't think it works actually
i'll take this way
i really have to watch my time well it's
been fun gold
welcome ben feingold
and viewers
you're just joining i'm playing grand
master wonderling
um
and i'm trying not to flag
but trying is the first step to failure
right
let's just trade everything
and we're trading a lot wow so we have
an end game
and night end game
okay after this pawn maybe
maybe not
never mind
i don't know what to do
black spawns are scarier than mine let's
play this move and then maybe this idea
finding a fork
um
play this
not sure if this is working
that's interesting
[Music]
no my time
oh i have this move
oh it's interesting
our king might be more active
i have 16 seconds left
oh no
this could be bad
no
wait let's try this
no
wait it's interesting
it might be a draw
no
wait
it's not a draw
i'm losing
uh he knows how to mate with king and
queen
ah
good game what a game
also thanks ben for raiding
oh that was a key game for the
tournament too
but well played to my opponent
shout out to ben
braiding with 309
yeah shout out gm
benjamin
gold
okay
so for those just joining i'm playing a
closed arena tournament
playing against you chicago
students and chess team members and
alum and maybe prospective students too
playing uh oh we're playing a folk beer
counter gambit
i was teaching this other day to um
tekken salami
who's a participant in this upcoming
crypto event
on chess.com
i did not go to u chicago
i attended university of illinois at
urbana-champaign for two years
then i transferred to webster university
okay so this is all what i showed a few
days ago on stream
bishop d2 and then e3 key move
that's a cool variation
instead of accepting a gambit i counter
gambit
and white's a bit slow to develop the
king side
yeah i know there's a line where you
play c6 um
which i just haven't looked into
maybe i should look into it
okay so i'm attacking the knight but i'm
also threatening queen h4
which
there's some calculation g3 takes
knight f3 queen e7
should be winning material for black
or the more fun calculation is key to
this this this this
oh wait a minute
this was an instinctive free move but i
think i would take the rook or no
no i would take back
because takes takes king e2 bishop g4
would win the house
thank you mcnubbits
subbing for four months
oh requesting an elephant
that's another opening i i want to look
more into at some point
if you want to see elephant gambit you
should watch min lei
i think he has like a whole youtube
series on the elephant
where he goes like very in detail
he's beaten me with it
a few times in that one match that we
had
oh shout out to wanderer15 who i think
raided
but i didn't realize
uh we have a will command
um i appreciate that i think will was
streaming some scrabble commentary
earlier
yeah big shout out to will
[Music]
the strongest scrabble player
in
our hearts
also in north america
my night trap my knights kind of trapped
and i don't have increment either
um
i play bishop g4
just should develop and
not get too low on time
ooh
i was more expecting this move
okay this is working out
i am calculating
never mind
let's castle queenside
yeah always the risk with berserking
like losing the increment but
[Music]
44 seconds should be enough time here
take with queen
now it should be force mate or that okay
nice game
yeah nice um
it's a fun opening for black if white
isn't like super well prepared
i think there are a few lines against
fog beer which
give white some advantage
um so i guess if you play king's gambit
you you have to study the folk beer
counter gambit
okay
i've definitely reduced uh
the difference between us
there was a point not too long ago
a wonder had
double the score as me
uh
play d4
oh critical bread is moving to st louis
in three weeks for a new job
i'm not sure if i'll be in st louis in
three weeks
but um
oh there's a funny trap takes takes
takes i lose the queen but then i win
the queen back
what was i saying
yeah i'm doing some traveling this
summer almost certainly
but uh
when i'm in st louis i'll i'll probably
be stopping by the chess club
more often
i can take this
in queen a4
i'm threatening some tricks
i was hoping for knight f6 there was a
cool trap there
and i have six would be bishop a6
this also looks fine
develop
realizing i probably should not have
berserked here
get some ideas to play e4
or c4
but yeah i definitely want to do it'd be
cool to like do some over the board meet
ups
accept some challenges
some nice chess sets outside the st
louis chess club
[Music]
i think e5 is a blender because i take
and
there's alignment
oh and thankfully after this at the very
least i have this
yeah there's some other
okay that was nice
real quick i'll share
um
yeah black played a different move order
but if night comes to f6
very surprising move bishop a6 is
winning for white
it's a fun london
trap which uh
wait what
why is this not winning
oh the queen is on d6
oh this trap only exists in this
variation i got confused
this variation bishop a6 never mind
i probably would have blitzed out fish
at a6 and then
just been worse if knight f6 were played
okay
i got confused
i should re-watch my lesson with andrea
botez
where i showed i showed the proper
version of that chap
it was a few weeks ago on youtube
okay
so
still trailing
i feel like in order to win this
tournament i'll need to play a wonder
berserk win
and then win a few more games quickly
and this is another comment saying
that i'm looking 10.
i guess i like if i want to look more
tan i could just change the filter
the color correction filter
but i do get a lot of sun yesterday so
that's probably more
more reason why i'm looking 10.
spent about two two and a half hours
yesterday
playing tennis
oh okay oh playing robert e
who oh robert e
i think it's a u chicago alum
let's play in england
have we we haven't played before
i wonder this is probably the robert e
from chat
ooh
let's play this move
pressuring the pawn
we have a reverse caro khan
it's a one night attack because i'm down
the tempo
ooh oh i'll play this line
so
i think the first game of the stream or
one of the first games of the stream
i had a similar position
where knight d2 e3 was played this will
be a bit different
okay
oh it's funny if c4 we'd have a reverse
french and the
timing or the tempe would
um would be the same because white would
lose a tempo
but okay this is no longer really any
sort of theory
um
maybe a little bit worse for white more
space for black
i'm gonna try and show no mercy here
and with this trade
there is uh
i was going to say there's prospect of
bishop a6
i think here i'll play bishop d7
some idea c5
yeah kind of a reverse win over
but with some small differences
i think i have all my minor pieces
developed
and usually white once upon
more pressuring the center
again i have to be wary of time
[Music]
um
play rook here
i would love to bust open the center
like c5
maybe next move
or if queen c3
getting out of the attack on the rook
that could be nice
okay so this is the first like major
blunder
i mean robert was still playing solid up
until
oh no you're queen
okay
thanks for the game robert e
okay just under 11 minutes left
probably time for like two or three more
games
people born after 2000 are not toddlers
yeah
they used to be toddlers
i guess this depends still
what year you were born
the time is kind of flying
the older you get oh robert e in the
chat
says lol omg that was so scary
yeah especially i guess that was our
first game
i know it can be scary
and there's so many people watching
but good game like you only made one
blunder
maybe some slaw some small inaccuracies
in the opening
so 25 total players in this tournament
oh okay moment of truth
what did we play before i'll play
another london
oh the bishop f5 line
maybe i'll mix things up
oh or he'll mix things up
interesting okay we'll play this one
okay i'm not at all prepared here
but i'll try and make logical moves
ooh that's kind of annoying let's play
this move
ah this is really annoying
this is opening
like b1
i feel like a beginner just developing
and undeveloping
[Music]
but maybe it's okay c3
okay somehow it's kind of okay
oh but it's still dangerous g4 probably
and knife
this is really dangerous because f2 is
vulnerable
um but maybe it's still okay
i'm terrified
now i know how robert e feels
kind of
maybe it's a different type of feeling
uh queen oh queen f2 is coming
rook h2
rig h2
no
oh no
[Music]
queen g1
rk2
i'm scared
don't hurt me
i'm getting hurt
night here i guess only move
some
i don't see it for his mates
oh
that's a good move
i just want to trade queens
no i'm getting mated
i got made
my beautiful king
oh there goes my peak rating
what to do that was rough that was a
cool opening actually
a lot of pressure
i was almost kind of diffusing it but i
didn't i didn't castle soon enough and
then my king got ripped from its its
home like a hurricane hit
or tony probably more like a tornado
where it just it picks up the home and
puts it like a few miles away
my king
just dragged all the way to h4
thank you vegas subbie
i might be coming to your city in like a
week or two
if you're from vegas
okay there's working time
staffer gambit never mind
but maybe
maybe
oh this is uh four nights
with bishop e2
okay
huh
yeah a little bit more happiness for
black
i'm taking time here because i'm not
used to this sort of uh position
i guess i'll castle queenside
make it more a bit more positional
i could have maybe won the pawn sooner
calculating knight h2 takes
okay here i can take
oh
[Music]
i can take here
and i don't think there's a great way to
defend the rook
because the knight's restricted by the
pawn
and the rook is basically trapped
in bishop f3 i take and defend
defend the queen
thank you sockfish
or sockfish
uh subbing for 15 months says happy
birthday
my birthday is less than three months
away
but thanks for the early wishes i guess
um okay let's take the thing
g1 is also controlled
eric will you tell me a story
oh what kind of story
usually when i have a story to tell i'll
tell it
oh but i didn't tell
the story from the other day i was going
to tell it
and then i got distracted
oh my thing
that's okay
i'm up enough material
visually should be a good move though
um
i was taking a walk the other day
uh just around the neighborhood
and i was walking by
the chess club
and world chess hall of fame
and
then i was about maybe 40 or 50 meters
away
i don't know why i said meters i'm an
american
maybe about 100 feet
um
i was some amount of distance away
where i saw someone in the distance
who looked like someone i knew
but i couldn't quite make it out
and then the closer i got
the more i realized who it was
it was a strong grand master
it was yasser sarawan he was just like
standing
[Music]
outside the world the world hall of fame
um there is some event going on like
some kickoff
to
[Music]
the grand chess tour
it was really cool they had like a
open bar basically outside
the oh my time
outside the hall of fame
so uh
the asser recognized me first
his eyesight was better than mine
or just his facial recognition skills
and then we stopped and chatted
um
okay let's take and meet
okay barely enough time there
um so it's cool to see yasser he said he
sometimes lurks in these streams
i said i would make him a vip but i
don't think he's too active in chat
more of a lurker
i forgot to take a selfie with him
i also forgot to ask him to collab
but maybe i'll see him again
it was cool yeah he's doing commentary
with maurice
for the
the super back grand chess tour in
romania
okay playing ihan
okay final game
stafford gamba time
maybe maybe not
feels like last game oh this is like
last game
the same opening except like castle
kingside
so i'll play an early g5
and then go for the quick kingside
attack
ooh
i want to play this but it's no good so
take and queen d7
we might end up trading everything or
not
i still want to attack
some
queen e7 h5 idea
how to do this
my knight is a little bit misplaced
if i play g4 there's h4
play h4 there's queen g4
i guess i'll play king b8
let's see what white is up to
points moving
concerningly quickly
yeah that's a good move
i might be in trouble here actually
keep the position as closed as possible
yeah i'm in trouble here
or am i
might still be okay
my time
oh
oh no
i'm in trouble
[Music]
or am i
maybe surviving
no that was a mouse slip
okay
i wanted to pin and win
interesting
ooh
the resign out of respect man
i was ready to try and uh
deal with the time pressure
oh
honestly if i was white i would probably
go for the flag but thanks to my
opponent for
um
i guess giving me a break there
also good game i played really well that
game
okay um
unfortunately i do have to go so i'm
wrapping things up
for this stream this is fun though i'll
probably put that on youtube